come on let's do it now let's do it
let's do it let's do it now I like to
start the stud that podcasts off with a
really upbeat song let's do it let's do
it now let's do it now because we are
then try to no turn around and open now
let's do it now let's do it now because
we are see it's hard it's late rhyme
with now yeah let's do it now let's do
it now because we are cows we are cow
house now now doesn't work now brow
let's do it all our pearls let's do it
now let's do it now coz we ate highbrow
that's pretty good we're not we're
highbrow yeah we're gonna take it to you
guys and keep it raw keep it raw because
we are we are cuz we break the law we
break the law we keep it wrong we keep
it raw we break the law see so I need
you I need you tonight come on it's
early it's Monday I'm hoping my face did
you eat an entire wheel to my head a
whole wheel of cheese and I drank way
too much wine you look Jabba panini and
I'm a little dehydrated Japanese that's
right so I'm holding holding a lot of
water one of us my face looks like a
human balloon it looks like a human
balloon that's why we are balloon
walking to the saloon
ok that's what we're gonna walk through
the saloon we say you suck at singing so
do I will I get it right well you got to
come up with ways to rhyme bro this is a
very good improv well I gotta be honest
we at my party on Saturday Justin myself
Tony and a few other guys sat around and
made funny how you thought you could
really be a singer why why would you say
that that's ok I saw Hamilton yeah and
masterpiece'
I'm [ __ ] try to say it's so hilarious
though but that reminded me because then
so J my brother than CLOB we're both
there and then clapping - yes I had no
idea where this he goes hey remember
when J 1 be a DJ of like No
oh he goes yeah like right when he got
at college he does it DJ and he talks oh
no oh God DJ that would embarrass me hi
Hannah
like I'm very hard to embarrass but if I
had a like when I was a kid I used to be
like I hated the name Brian so I'd be
like what's your name and I was like
Chris oh that's yeah because it's so
much better than my name Oh words but no
but DJ tap out that's alright and then
Jay goes you will you only gave me the
idea cuz Tavis just for bigots probably
work is you're good for marketing did
you tap DJ tap out
DJ tap now I'm J just doesn't excite
about anything so he just really they're
like this then with the beat drops ready
for it doom get up y'all everybody get
up you know get up y'all yeah yeah he's
not
DJ tap out yeah I don't see him as being
it couldn't be a worse job for him beer
no this whole area for a long time about
talking at you live let's hit this dance
floor paper no you don't yell like that
now you have to though you got it you
can't be like Jays really Jay used to
introduce us at the fine kids live for
[ __ ] came along because we might never
never did it I never heard him ladies
and gentleman
Bryan Callen Brent's job at least put
your hands together here they're two
people yeah really
okay well I mean I I remember that my
buddy Jeff Beecher he had a thing called
Beacher's Madhouse I've been there yeah
it will used to be when he had the worst
ice to yell at him and I don't mind
saying this on I had the worst he didn't
know how to like he'd go come on guys
let's go do this guys no no
go down I have to be like just go I'll
use it bro let's go up let's do this get
excited let's go let's rock it out and
he go alright let's rock and roll
nothing dude your baby may be just
trying to switch it up
well boot down these Beacher's Madhouse
still here was in the Roosevelt Hotel
I guess I don't know what happened to it
that's some good times though yeah the
place was always easier to in Vegas oh
yeah I had some time through the AMC
that well I am seated because because
the girls 1,500 people well now there's
a joint 1,500 people so I would go there
and I dress like a pimp and then I would
go I mean it was the hottest girls in
all that you were the guy how old were
in 35 34 he was he said 37 38 I've made
money 34 people good money and I and it
was like and I wasn't really gonna stand
at that oh you were just [ __ ] around
he just wanted me to come in you
thinking did I was circus day oh I was I
was on your deal and listen this
appalling Beacher's Madhouse dick asked
Bret Ernst ask Steve Byrne we have I I
was making out at one point making out
with the Los Angeles Lakers
Cheerilee what were you dressed like now
I'm not what we dressed like I was in a
cream colored suit
let me explain come zoot suit explain a
couple things to you explain couple
things there was a I was dancing with
tan she was at well but let's let me go
through it can I go through the night I
met my wife
sure well no you might appreciate this I
meet a girl who is she sees me on stage
and she's so good-looking I'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on like she was so
good-looking and we're dancing and we're
making out and she takes me up to her
room I take her up to my room and she
goes but you're so like everybody knows
you in this room isn't a suite and I go
yeah I know it's they just give me this
room I don't really pay attention she
goes oh but this is the kind of room I
would get so I was like this is very
strange
so we start to get it on and she goes so
here's the thing
for me to like you here I have to go to
work
where's much because I work at Spearmint
Rhino and I make $1,000 and so it's
really hard for me to like if I'm gonna
lose my shift and I have to kind of like
clear point
yes I'm like oh so wait so you want to
pay your shift yeah I know bronze you
want $1,000 good gentlemen you don't
waste your time yeah yeah so I was like
but see what bothered me was you're
hustling me just ask me for a grand and
then maybe we can have a conversation no
that's not fun
well it's not fun but the problem is I
had a lot of opportunities downside no
you didn't know you'd have to pay for
the big right so I go wait a man you got
me up here right now and you're you're
pouring salt on my tongue I could even
say that rears right I can eat I can eat
for free downstairs and also you tried
to hustle me so I go guess what I ain't
paying I'm not paying you $1,000 that's
actually she beat the other one I've
said she just been no but she kept
playing no but I don't I want to be here
I just don't want to miss my ship I'm
like yeah I know this is an amazing play
you get me up here you got your shirt
off you're ridiculous looking but we'll
see you later
you're cheap bro a cheap I'm cheap I
kicked her out chin would have paid a
hard cash for that she was so stupid I
would 200 let me let me be honest it's
not that that she is she was that hot
where you'd be like any guy would be
like thousand dollars well I can't play
pay rent this month I have some cash but
I'll figure it out why can't they have
square why can't they ask where by the
way I won't they take that $1,000 tab
yeah I didn't have a whole lot of money
bitty [ __ ] take square doesn't make him
crazy money don't charge me sir fee yeah
thousand dollars was a lot of money
still is for anybody but and but you
know it was one one things that even if
you were broke you would think about it
if she was standing in front of you I
don't care who you are
you'd be like I gotta give her money go
to your buddy and go I gotta borrow
money right now pay back I swear to God
so anyway I kick her out I go back
downstairs I'm gonna jump ahead I'm
making out with the Los Angeles Laker
cheerleaders now yeah now what do you
mean Bry one to not make it round yeah
yeah yeah and then then this beautiful
woman comes up to me and wife you shut
it all down
I shouted that's a smart move so let me
the straight those tens yeah they're
trying to suck the skin off your dick
yeah the Los Angeles cheerleaders
yeah nice on the dab why didn't shut it
down I'm gonna grow up though I got a
girl
the time was this big model and she was
living in New York so it was just a
thing oh you guys are just counting me
remember talking and then he got serious
you don't let me get the goods for three
months that's that proof yeah and then I
got serious yeah but three months she's
a prude paint off paid off made you wait
hung just out of reach again yep and she
didn't get syphilis which i think is
outrageous that she didn't get syphilis
I took my pills
that's smart simplest would freak me out
that's a biggie syphilis is a problem
cause you get a store on the end of your
dick apparently I don't know if that's
later but you know that no no don't
spoil a picture of syphilis I don't want
to get thin oh it's like a cold sore
until you dig maybe I don't know get a
man yeah I don't [ __ ] with it no I was
over Wisconsin I was in Madison
Wisconsin some of the best crowds
maybe I've ever experienced ever on some
of the best shows I've ever had Saturday
early show might have been um maybe one
of my best shows ever best crowds best
shows ever
yeah I'm just writing comes in handy
I've never been more excited about
stand-up in my life this has been an
amazing time for me and then you're in
Philly next week Madison was interesting
because it's all college a lot of it's a
college town so it's a lot of college
kids boy do I feel old [ __ ] do I
world
I had a 18 year old night you know yeah
my show in Long Beach they set to take
pictures they walked up because you just
21 over which I see people can play all
the time I don't set that stuff they do
I have no idea I'd let 12 year olds in
Brighton come by about 12 years old
these 18 19 year old watched up and I
was like how or you got that mean crazy
right [ __ ] I forget man I'd swoon its
nuts
it really is it's amazing yeah so how
about on that what Wisconsin our bad
fight Philly's a nice short flight
Philly will take me five hours Billy's
not yet all day yeah I'll be there this
weekend come see me at the helium comedy
club dude how about I go to I went to
New York on Wednesday so I view a
red-eye I took a red-eye I get wheel and
I only got about maybe two hours three
hours of sleep on the plane yeah because
there was a
to Jonah on the plane that
like suck dick I'm trying to be frank
here
all right okay they just a [ __ ] no
strange talk and I didn't know then and
the West Hollywood list okay okay so you
guys can put to a two together there was
a lot of this a lot of this okay so this
should be a rule that would earn the
night flights like that when trying to
sleep they can't talk because I sound my
cats well just even if they weren't
raging gay they shouldn't be able to
talk hey what the hell of course your
cell phone's going off but you don't say
like when people are trying to sleep
they shouldn't be able to sit up front
and just talk the night off I shouldn't
be so are you being are you sort of
saying that anybody who speaks like this
it should be censored and wear a muzzle
no no no no anyone gets no gay or
straight should not be allowed to talk
from if your flights loading to me and
they should not be allowed to talk right
but do you do you do couldn't serves the
list though that's better cats hissing
at each other like serpents like snakes
which like it says to click snakes on a
plane yeah it's like snakes on a plane
to overgrown snakes yeah but just
trouble a couple of Chatty Cathy's so
can I keep waking up keep waking up like
I get about two hours sleep I get off
the plane go from there straight to the
press conference with Deontay Wilder
alright cool man
so I'm tired I get off the plane and the
driver picks and I go uh-huh
we're closed right here's yeah we're
closed however it is 7:30 and the UN is
in town the trumps in town so let me
just oh yeah here's ways two and a half
hour oh my god I could've told you cuz
let it go you gotta go through the
Midtown Tunnel he started laughing on it
I feel sick
you just started laughing and then so I
went straight from there right to the
interview this gate does crawl up on the
back seat and go to sleep [ __ ] try to
just tough that stop in odds the worst I
know that is I know I've done that New
York flight has done it but it's an inch
well it's a [ __ ] when you that traffic
getting from JFK to the city is always a
mother van and I've been stuck in that
tunnel I've been stuck and I told him I
went I went I could get out and walk
there faster in terms of you could you
go my gosh you almost feel like walking
yeah there's nowhere to walk there's
well I don't know where I'm going
I almost got out and walked in the
tunnel it was I was stuck in I've never
seen traffic like that ever in my life
people complain about la traffic oh then
I've never seen rush hour in New York
traffic is that area yeah it was not a
built that was built in the 50s you know
it's not 1504 though it's not meant for
though at that many cars that's what I
came up with the rail they're building
that [ __ ] bozo you should scoff to
subway do I look like a [ __ ] ninja
turtle do you do that I'm I'm not from
New York yeah I don't know we're just to
get off and jump on and get stuck a [ __ ]
don't like Seinfeld he's being a
Seinfeld you see his new special he's a
great brilliant really this is why
so it basically it tells his story like
where he started and cuts in and out
like where he grew up hit they have his
first ever stand-up just shows his video
but the whole our special is all his old
jokes too through the years now you want
to do it just to show that his jokes
hold up over time I had no idea of what
laughing my ass off that's great
this is the best part he's sitting there
in New York and he's like in in the
middle of the road and they took every
page of notes he's never wrote jokes and
it goes like four oh yeah roads roads
and roads and he's like this is every
joke I've ever read and they put them on
it's amazing that's amazing it's
ridiculous top writing man no they just
yeah that is that's something some
inspiring [ __ ] you should you should you
should see this know stuff but no his
his stuff is like it's when he wrote it
in the you know the 70s and there's that
old piece of paper and you'd go through
might go this one was funny that shows
him saying it Wow but he's just trying
to prove that his comedy holds up over
time I didn't know was that a no idea
but then I did research on it is
interesting I gotta watch that that's
incredible
then he did it at UH get the name of the
place but where he very first start and
they have his sign-up sheet well one of
the things about doing stand-up for a
long time is that you miss your old bits
like sometimes you have great bits like
some of the old things that I used to do
like you have your best of sand yeah I
don't do them anymore
but you can't no I mean that right now
I'm thinking I have a whole different
hour I'm thinking about I'm not thinking
about different but the comedy has
changed like the old school guys like
Jay Leno a lot of
other guys they never changed the rack
but don't you feel like no I'm not
always changing do it but like today's
day and age like people want new new new
new so let's say you saw you in Philly
this weekend if you're in Philly this
weekend and you do the same bit you did
last year you will never do that be able
to go back then yeah and because people
like what's now what's now and try to
compete with it run and digital and
YouTube and all this stuff in social
media you can't do those old asset I
also feel like you know so much of
stand-up for me is just trying to be
original in my expression so whatever is
going on with me over the year since
I've been to Philly right is it it's so
different and I'm you're different
Thursday's yeah and I'm less thinking
about different things so as long as you
stay true to that you know it does take
a long time to gel a whole hour but you
know I'll definitely come least new
stuff like when I was in Dublin I won't
name the the comic who they're referring
to big name comic like yeah last show we
went to was this guy and goes he did the
same stuff we see him do see it all the
time like anything at all Chios the
crowd literally went dead silent like
we've seen it man like we came here the
magic trick yeah we see we really know
what's going on like where's the new
stuff you've been here in three years
that's amazing I can't understand that
because you you know there's something
good about being bored with your stuff
like after a while when you do it enough
it's a very good thing for a comic
because you know you've got a key it's
like anything else if you don't use it
you lose it you've got to just keep
evolving it's really easy for anyone to
be like really good this would be like
look at martial arts guys okay so then
it used to be your martial arts master
he would sit and he would teach and he
never got tested never fought yeah one
of the things that the Brazilians would
do is if you're a black bow if your hand
so or any of those guys they were always
rolling with their students they were
staying current relevant right and you
know that from MMA you can't sit back on
your laurels I mean you you have to be
you know and III think that there's
something very important about that and
one of the things that I like about
maybe it may be and I don't know if this
is true but maybe with the advent of the
internet and people have so much access
to so much you better be
you can't sit back there's more
competition yeah man you better be
relevant every condition yeah it's much
harder you know otherwise it really it's
hard to be in also you might be doing I
don't know a joke on Trump
well there's 50 other comics talk on
Trump
and people have access to it now where
before if he did some Drake oh yeah you
know that's Brendan's joke but well if
he was the first one to do it he was
usually the guy who's getting credit not
only that but something that people
don't realize is that before the
internet when I was doing stand-up like
before like people had access to this
like you remember the internet is what
6,000 days old I mean it's very very
short you know it's uh it's known for a
while but yeah about 6,000 days old it
might be a little more maybe 7,000 days
all it's kind of weird to think about
okay I mean the Internet as we know it
where we have access to it okay it's
very very short period of time so when
in the let's just take 95 96 97 even
2000 when you were doing stand-up
because people like so I couldn't do the
jokes in New York that I did just didn't
just do I wanted to check the 6000 yeah
but wouldn't you just if you do uh that
hold is internet cuz it can be biased if
you type in the exact thing you know I'm
sayin how many days old is the you know
I'm talking about the day that's ten
thousand four hundred days yeah okay so
ten thousand pretty pretty short period
of time think about but ten thousand
days is not really true because what I'm
saying is that the the entertainment for
everyone have access so that we use of
the way we use it it's really not long
it's I mean think about when you started
really using email when you you were
able to just go online and see anything
you wanted that was probably what 90 mm
I mean 2000 2001 right so so you're not
talking it is it is it seems like a long
time but it's not in the grand US 2000
was right and so 15 years before that
before that 15 years seems like a long
time but not really historically it's
just not like think about it it's really
in our life though I mean let's half my
life
yeah I guess it is for you for me it's
not yeah you know for me think about
I've been around 50 years so it's only
15 years of my life that's a short
period time yeah
for that like me and Rogan and all those
guys in Burr we were we were doing
stand-up in a time with in the day at a
time when it yeah when there wasn't that
so you're say you you couldn't do the
jokes I remember so well you couldn't do
jokes in New York you had to change your
act from New York to LA and a lot of
times like did the jokes that you did in
New York were not the same as LA yeah it
was you'd be a guy he's now a comic or
he's a New York comic yeah and and now
anything I do here works in Madison
works in Philly was in New York works
because we are all sort of kind of the
same under umbrella yeah yeah that's new
that's new historically that's new
historically period that we're all kind
of sharing the same culture like you
know even even though amazing like even
in the jihadi websites like and sort of
the ISIS websites they talk about
transgender issues they talk about
climate change they talk about all these
things the only difference is they blame
you know they say well it's all been
predicted yeah yeah but they're all
we're all having the same conversation
the other thing that's really really
interesting is that we're all kind of
arguing for different points of view
like say the left and the right using
the same language yeah we're also using
the same language what's the true line
to everybody liberalism right so human
rights but we all have a different way
of going about it you know it's really
interesting
yeah it's so we're all kind of a group
we are speaking the same language the
argument happens around how to get there
everywhere yeah good luck figuring that
out yeah dude I start watching we've
been traveling see deaf haven't seen it
what's called confession true
confessions on Netflix you guys know I'm
telling you no time I it's [ __ ] nuts
it's something confessions on Netflix
let's see yeah confession tapes so they
should what they do is they the the
first haven't seen the first one spoiler
if you're about to want to eat and it's
old-school [ __ ] but so there is a a kid
who was they were in Vancouver his
family his dad had a masters
Engineering his mom's educated Muslim
descent I forget where they came from
but they were in Vancouver and the kid
was at Cornell his best friend went to
Cornell his best friend was this white
kid they're getting they were in
highschool friends then went to college
they come back I'm like whatever winter
break and they find when they're back
and winter break the mom the dad and the
sister all murdered brutally beaten with
a bat like these brutal brutal so these
two kids were staying the the son and
the best friend was staying with the
family the son of the murdered yeah I'm
and dad yes staying with family so there
you go all right right flag you know
they go so the cop the detective they're
interviewing him he was where interview
him and go well your mom you know you
obviously he saw it he goes do you know
your mom my dad died and your sister and
you know how do you feel bad he goes
they took my Walkman well and he's like
alright that's a weird way to deal with
it so then that then the white guy his
best friend call the cops if super
suspect like he wasn't that like if I
saw three dead murdered people I mean I
would be I'd be a corner like exactly my
way you know what I would not say well
you're right you might run away so the
kid calls knees like there's there's
like some dead bodies and and then they
saw they it looks like someone broke in
so then they all right let's see if
their alibi holds up so they said they
drove to Seattle
they ate here and then they they went to
a club and then they had a late-night
meal here so the cop goes when they're
going through it like right so they call
those places and they say when when
they're just telling what they're doing
that guy that makes sense I they were
they weren't here okay all right so he
goes but then when you look into it and
they were the way they were acting and
stuff like that it's a little weird so
they they call back those restaurants
they you know what they order and she
goes oh they want to make sure we saw
their ID they worded wine in a salad and
split it these are two college boys why
- South so
I would you didn't warrant how I
remember they're very smart why was your
to wine so they have to look at your ID
so they remember seeing you yeah there
were the wine so when when they went to
the movie why would they go to the movie
well one that the movie there's no way
that could be at the house coming the
murder to the movies two hours long yes
they bought movie tickets yeah
so then after when all that's been done
then when they go to the late-night
place and ask for and then then they go
to a club why would they go to club you
know they know the club club close that
to speed would remember them causing up
a stir mm-hmm so they put all this
together this is the cops they didn't
know how to think this is good like out
so they put all this together right and
I'm like these [ __ ] and they
swear they didn't do it then they look
into it and there's an insurance claim
where they get like two hundred seventy
five thousand dollars one of those
parents dies so like three months go by
they buy new Mustangs this the other
thing the kids take back off to Canada
the murder happened in icier in Seattle
in Seattle I think the cops were dealing
with it but they take off the Vancouver
so they can't get to them right this is
where it gets weird though
so the there's a funeral three days
later they say the the Muslim kid freaks
out the TV when he sees his parents
being buried he's like what I was
supposed to be nullifies this how could
they do this why would they do it this
fast now they're balls deep in the
Muslim religion everyone knows a Muslim
religion it's three days and the
family's supposed to clean the body yeah
order everything for three days so I
keep it's fake man he knows is he's so
much like when you're that dived in
culture you know this yeah so while that
happens this is where it gets weird so
wait so the kid the kid sees his parents
being buried on TV on TV it's a big deal
it's a huge murder he says he freaks out
from this that he's that like a friend's
house been three days already
oh yeah it's been like yeah it's been
three days but that's how you found
those prints were me and Barry on TV he
acts like he had no idea that why would
they bear him this fast and all this
stuff like well I give nothing you know
so this is where Canada shoutout to
Canada for this Canha has a division
months go by can't heads a division
where they have these I guess basically
they're FBI I forget what they call
Canadians versions FBI they like
Scotland Yard
or something like that I figure what the
Mounties Matt's on the mountain tease
yeah notes up mouth the Royal the Royal
Mountie but they end they have a buffalo
as their logo so they they're like
something's we can't figure out
something's going on with these two kids
so they have this guy pretend they're in
the mob and he gets like they know where
he's going he's going to get a haircut
so they have him out front of getting a
haircut and he pretends like his car's
down he's like I need help
and the kid helps them they just hit it
off he was let's go get a drink so then
months go by they've become friends guys
in a mob all this stuff and then he goes
hey if you're gonna work for us
we need an you know I've heard some
stuff man and so they film him and he
they're consi trying to get it out I'm
like come on man those murders in
[ __ ] Vancouver like what you do if
I'm gonna help you he can't come back on
us man keep a lot of heat on us so they
keep pressing him for it and finally the
kid gets a confession is when the [ __ ]
would you do it he was during the movie
you think we'd be gone went back to in
the movie and did it so he done they do
all this stuff then they bring another
guy they get him to confess when Canada
that's legal so they record him
confessing it but they were saying and
they have this fragment or something
they're saying that's not fair because
these kids are 19 and they want to be
party crew they want to be cool yeah
that's true that's how I said but they
didn't have they even have a ton of
editing that's only evidence they have
smart kids by the way my kids no they
didn't pull it off okay because then
they they went back there tried in
Seattle and for the first time Seattle
the courtroom was like yeah bad evidence
we're gonna let it hold up and that's
all they had that was them saying those
during that back that's a little iffy
because the kid did want to be part of
the mafia that's what that's we see that
they have a friends a guy who's who
specializes in these confessions like
dealing with this and like they're 19
yeah and that was their argument you
know what they got both got three
lifetime sentences no parole well if
they did it I get it you know but you
gotta watch those cuz I'm like I'm like
do I go back in front of them like they
did it they didn't do it because there's
this terrorist group in the United
States who murders like cuz that the dad
was disappointed in the mosque Muslim
mosque the mosque in cana-don't point
the right way and he's saying it's an
automat day yeah they don't point the
right way what they should series that
cause enough you're supposed to pray so
when you pray you pray toward Mecca
that's what you say yeah you've seen a
lot of Omar and he was like causing all
this because when you go to a hotel room
sometimes in the Middle East they'll
have a arrow pointing which way yeah so
the dad was like causing some of that up
and they think maybe this group do it
and then some of it
it's a strange man it's tough I I what
you can't do it very what you can't do
is give the kids three life sentences at
19 well yeah this is where else he got
tricky the white boy though he was
handsome
the lawyer you've got caught [ __ ]
lawyer his defense lawyer I beg your
pardon
yeah and where and it delayed it the
girl three hours it was a woman who was
his attorney that's hot
yet caught [ __ ] really not hot she was
not hot but he was amusing while that's
going on he's in you know jail prison
for like three four years and he's going
on got delayed about two years I was
giving it to her he's giving it to it
yeah yeah I just feel like you guys are
the guy is literally over and over come
on come on come on come on wait till you
see it he's like broke quit [ __ ] me
you got it uh he and he goes I we have
that's a weird way that's weird way to
get in the convention you're in America
it's illegal in Canada so these guys
wanted to be part of the mob and that's
this is this how it happened that they
go the mob guys the fake mob guys go
listen we got some heat on you we have
some rats in the in the police station
down in Vancouver and in Seattle we know
and they brought up like government
wrote up a fake thing that I look what
we got a hold up they're gonna try to
get you in this this and they that's
entrapment it's [ __ ] that's right and so
that he goes how'd you do it and the
kids are you know yeah I probably said
that that's that's his my finger cheap
way to get I agree somebody if you
didn't commit murder yeah
even at 19 if you didn't commit murder
yeah one just like did I get it man I
wish I had two I didn't kill anybody
Yeah right yeah or you want to be cool
and you want to be part of that gloves
what they said and so now you're gonna
go after the fourth month you're gonna
go [ __ ] it yeah yeah
we went to the movies and then we did
during them but it makes sense though it
does make sense it's super sceptile
here's the other thing that they
probably did it yeah probably you gotta
watch it know these things that's what
the cop was I'm positive they did it
like but they have all these other leads
they didn't follow up on like legit
leads like this guy had like all these
suspects from this terrorist group that
killed people before like this is their
names where they live the bat that they
used you know like and that leaders
didn't follow up on so weird thing man
with so many of these things there's so
much evidence it's so interesting
there's a bunch on but this is the first
one it's so [ __ ] interesting and it's
called what confession files or true
confession tapes - didn't tapes but I
couldn't believe these the two best
these guys are known for being the best
to infiltrate them the Mafia yeah but
when you listen like that like those are
the best they would just throw an F word
every but come on but I can't [ __ ] go
down the Train like [ __ ] they just
keep cos I'm like that's not the way
mafia is Tom yeah the horrible actors it
was you wait DC I'm like oh God well
they do that with like when you're gonna
when you're gonna place a hit on
somebody since there are people that
will go to soldier a fortune magazine or
whatever and they'll try to hire
somebody but the cops have you know
there are different kinds of people they
have they have they staged that stuff a
lot didn't you call them and so what
they'll do is they'll go yeah I want to
kill my husband they go all right and
then you meet with them they do thing
and then what they'll do and I think
it's by law or at least in some states
before they're gonna quote unquote do it
they're not gonna do it they call you
back and then you sure you want to do
this sure you want to do this and when
you say yes then they come in since
that's fair to me those people should go
to prison that's fair job yeah cuz how
long would somebody so would you put
somebody in prison for life for that I
would if you're ordering a hit and you
know that that's the way it is I what
about the circumstances if you what
happens if you sexually molest me since
I was six years old well those are
always gonna comment and I'm 35 now and
you're trying to sexually molest you
know use typically that's not who does
it don't say it's not about giving you
on TV it's a wife elect money or
whatever in your [ __ ] yeah I'm not you
know you're bad person I'm saying
keeps my kids well that's like a woman
so when a woman kills her husband after
years of abuse and she's doing life and
prisoners should not do life and bright
but it happens I get pissed so hard
yeah me too let's go piss come on let me
help you piss let me let's piss when you
say piss when you drag it out
I got a piss out of my day Dan and
Benton you see the fights have you seen
the fights there's so many fights this
weekend was it o SP and I don't know I
didn't see it first of all Bellator
stole the show relic tours card was the
best of the weekend really yeah how
about Aaron Pico told you out my [ __ ] is
bad so anyone gave me [ __ ] cuz I succumb
to LeBron James as far as being a
prospect he was writing at 16 he was
resting on an international level at 16
years old well no he would start
wrestling way before that oh no I know
at 8 he was doing boxing in rest yes but
he was wrestling international yeah tons
of free 64 he uh he looked good he still
he was still you know it's only second
fight so there's gonna be still some
mistakes he just he ate a lot of shots
till then clip stuff open he took some
hits appreciative he he knocked this guy
out so bad really oh my god
he don't wear the uppercut like you
would just like a knob get you to throw
like [ __ ] around we don't like rock
this guy really so bad so what are the
mistakes is he like it yeah he's just
he's just ceases to aggressive like he's
not he's not not fluid enough yet no
yeah he's just he's just there like he's
well he's 20 great though he's 20 he
looked he looked great not this kid out
so and he fights if he has a ways to go
like Ivor 55 in his last fight was no 45
his last fight was at 55 even though he
found a seven here so he fights up 45
but they should keep giving guys like
this like years will don't toss them you
know these pop right sure now he's a few
years off from that but he's gonna be
he's gonna be champ but you know that's
a slow boy fight Fighting's you've seen
that way because like a 20 even though
he's been fighting his whole life I
guess MMA is just something that just
you you have to season for a while like
when you're thirty like there's a big
difference
right I mean there's this young
champions they're studs but it's just
like there's he has no experience it
makes much
okay wrestling doesn't count it's gonna
help that's not the same well you got to
put it won't be like you'd be like doing
just shows at the belly room and then
the next week you're doing a stadium
give me a difference so just the energy
of the crowd and all that stuff also
costs also too much it's just a
different animal competitions but like
kids there's a lot you just got to put
together to experience we get there
mm-hmm but yeah I thought boy looked
good Roy had his hands full royal it
good man Henderson got screwed got he's
a Oh lorenz larkin lost again
oh and two now in the in Bellator which
I'm surprised lost appalled daily bad
knockout to Tampa news out on this field
daily still fighting this was a bad
knockout to ya belt or stole the weekend
UFC Japan was good man the claudia deja
entourage fight like I watched the first
round I tweeted out too soon because I
caught up all if I watched every launch
fury Parker boxing the the UFC Bellator
I watched another boxing match so I
caught up on all the fights in I got
through everything and then I save
Jessica and Raj and Claudia deja last
cuz everyone's like best female fight
ever fight of the year people were
talking about at my party that's the
best ever bug no no Claudia Daisy got
her ass whooped she just kept coming
forward and getting but she's got her
ass whooped
unless she got beat up just gonna dodge
just beat her ass Jesus like was
throwing it and Clyde you dated ages my
favorite writer especially as female
fighters 115 pounds
really I prefer to watch her over I like
in Johanna I prefer to watch Claudia
just cuz she mixes up she you know like
she goes after not that you want a dozen
I just I don't know Claudia if I had to
pick cloudy's fun and she got she got
beat on Josh beat her half Wow those not
the great feeling on fight of all time
she got tired she just gets tired at the
end of the round like the second half of
the fight Gil teen and just just gonna
dodge literally picked her up I was like
saw the bus line slam dude read the
times I've seen Jessica and Josh
fighters she just seems to keep coming
forward taking shots and just closes
that gap unless she's fine your abs and
butt
klaudia to me Claudia is the best 150
pound fighter in the world not named
Johanna in the first round she was sick
she was so good Claudia Claudia yeah I
see even the first round like Top Ramen
yeah yeah I don't know I don't know I
mean I might give that someone had the
one just had 30 2530 26 30 20 slides
though ass-whooping I had a weird dream
about Matt Mitrione like a nightmare a
nightmare because we kept saying he kept
going hey fool I'll punch a hole right
through your face and I was in your
dream yep and I was like I know you I
know you would he goes but I will I'll
punch a hole right to face and then I
would find myself for whatever reason
taking pictures with him this is so
[ __ ] weird
we take picture and I put my hand on his
back and I was like he's so [ __ ]
strong I was like oh [ __ ] he's gonna
[ __ ] me up
nope I just felt his back and we take
picture and then you go I'm gonna put
our holes right to your face I go I know
when I'm aware that you are going to do
that we kept the green with him and then
I woke up when and then we fought for
real yeah terrible dream
and then OSP with Okami devon flew choke
how you get cotton of Vaughn flew choke
in 2017 is amazing
why and especially when you're fighting
the guy who speed there's only I think
there's only been five ever done in the
UFC and OSP has three of them he's gonna
change his name to Vaughn flew they says
Vaughn true choke now it's oh no it's no
speech okay so his P choke how he taught
him that and listen OSP is not a high
level grappler but he does not launch
oak like you said last time you're like
this is his danger that's just that
maybe it's just he's so strong you've
rolled with him yeah I have and and he's
not well he's not world-class on the
ground now that choke he does is
obsolete world-class you show how yeah
it's it's literally but it's easier if
you're not if no one sits in your [ __ ]
okay but it's in because you hang onto a
the head to that's the only way to do it
okay
it's the only the only way it's one the
only chokes the on't that set up like
this it's the only choke which you can't
avoid if you avoid doing this if you
stop holding on to the yeah and you
can't get that it's if you're fighting
him and fro calm me to have 1,000
fights under his belt at the highest
level for him to get choked out in the
first minute by the one chose by he only
do you know right it's like sneak oh no
that's the thing be yeah well there's
nothing sneaky
there's nothing sneaky yeah the Vaughn
flu joke is not a sneaky joke so if I
have you in a headlock you're saying
yeah just let go of it
don't guess so if I got you like this no
no no yes well it's always if like you
know I'm saying like when he takes him
down you shouldn't
you're not gonna tap me out of here when
you take me down you know that's what
it's from when he can't get out of it
okay I hang on to the head right you can
set that choke up unless I make the
mistake of hanging on the head to him
yeah he can't wrap your arm and there's
certain traps and baits can do but if
you're fighting OSP let go I I kind of
packed her I didn't let go so maybe you
like you got a panic cause I walk but
the thing is a tendency when you go on
and then we have the UFC glove on you
can't get out he went this he choked him
to sleep yeah that's Krause he's a big
strong guy and he's obviously
world-class at it so once it's there
you're [ __ ]
yeah but for a guy of Oh commies nobody
gets stuck there's crazy jujitsu and
embossing Parker who's done New Zealand
heavyweight who everyone but I see all
the DM z-- I see all the emails everyone
said you never talked about Parker when
you talk about heavyweights and when you
talk about water and Joshua
I don't think Parker's at their level
I'm gonna get so much [ __ ] for this and
he's new New Zealand I think he's great
I think Wilder Joshua would be a tough
fight for him he definitely beat fury he
looked good I'm not saying he can't beat
those guys I think it'd be a tough fight
for him you he walked out with his dad
and uncle with their shirts off I put it
on my Instagram story there's I'm shape
but it was cool to see yeah it's cool
see I'm [ __ ] now you you uh he looks
great no I'm not saying he can't be
world he's already world champ
I mean he's WBO I figure were champions
he's already champ but to unify the
belts and he fought in man
Chester we're Fury's hometown and also
you define Manchester kind of show those
fans you know he wants job marker is
clearly Simone's my size partially
Simone is your size how big is Dion take
compare it to you
uh I mean don t [ __ ] fall six seven
yeah six eight yeah then handshape yeah
handsome and and very into fashion is we
were great diamond I'm telling great
he's the personality and he was
hilarious really he was great and he was
just talking about you know how he our
conversation you know I don't give it
away but our conversation I'm just like
why aren't you the face of box in
America why aren't you a bigger deal
you're the first heavyweight champion
American champion seven years 30 of
these 34 no with 33 knockouts I think
like why don't you but your child hold
on before you answer let me tell you he
he and I go aunty more people watch anti
Josh provides a new fight he's from
England and he goes what he was
hilarious about he's like what kind of
[ __ ] is fact how do you refer foreigner
how do you root for a light-skinned
ninja he's how you roof I'm from here
importantly scared you guys vote root
for him he's like ain't that some [ __ ]
and he goes then he goes in and everyone
wants to make fun of my record like I'm
fighting like these you know these
powder puffs and all the stuff he goes
it's heavy weights there's might be six
of us who are good or we supposed to
just fight each other all the time he
was looking at those guys records
they're not fighting anyone either until
recent and he goes I'm it's true and and
I told this interview I go I don't get
why you're fighting Ortiz I think it's a
bad idea and he goes moto you as most
people do that's why I'm doing it
why bad idea in what says Ortiz has 17
followers on Twitter and he's the
toughest matchup in the world he is he's
that we don't know how old he is
he's from Cuba yeah he lives in Miami we
have no idea is he's yes four hundred
amateur finally good he's really good he
has a granite chin he's a southpaw and
no one knows who he is they call him the
boogeyman the boxes didn't want scared
him no wants to fight like that Cuban
school of boxing to I mean [ __ ] you know
they're really and beyond a wanted this
fight well I was gonna say that I feel
like will
talking about him if he can beat Anthony
Joshua that's that's the fight right
yeah but that's not fair
like you tears yeah I guess but it
doesn't make sense right the most
visible - I feel like that's that's the
fight what is your take on that
yeah he has to I mean Joshua would be
the next fight they want to fight each
other like Deonte was saying here's what
I wanna do is unify all the belts and
calve unity it's smart he goes to have
this belt here doesn't feel WBO tell
them all over the place no it should be
one that was it because they can unify
the motors no they can there's promotes
but you can unify the belt okay if him
and Joshua fight to be huge I bet they
doing in Vegas that's of great fight
Joshua's fight in October and then why
was fighting in November I date that
fight is kind of in the works sort of
right a minutes in that to me I view it
like they're basing a pride style
tournament yeah well there's four guys
in tournament the winners of those will
fight Wow
but our team also has a tough fight to
the you know the you know T's
Wyler has a tougher matchup against
Ortiz a southpaw oh this guy's so what
did Wilder say about our teeth he's
confident obviously but I do what
there's a shitload of yeah yeah he's 22
and oh or somebody the 24 no he's a
monster he just fought five months ago
but I told him straight up doing nothing
I'm like you know what - terrible like
it's a rough matchup you think no I know
I know I'm a knock him out man
you just believes himself he's like I
just because I know it's a tough matchup
I see this stuff man he's like I just
see it I see it happening I you know he
didn't he come to boxing later than most
about 19 really 21 bet 19 very young his
belt his goal was to play football for
UFC Alabama he's from Alabama and so but
his daughter was born with a spine issue
and he couldn't make money fast enough
so that's when I went to boxing Wow
when to boxing and then went to the
Olympics to pick it up at night she's a
piece of freakish things and this what I
did this was kind of my whole thing for
him that what makes him different is
he's a better athlete and all these guys
that's his one thing he has he's a B
this footwork well sir Sergio Martinez
the game
into boxing at 20 from Argentina yeah
he's a soccer player yeah soccer player
really good soccer player so who's
Martinez was amazing yeah so but still
20 21 is really really late really late
man I mean for the guys have been boxing
since they were 10 you know super late
yeah it's like that's a testament to his
a lot of us hilarious man really yeah
he's funny guy it's funny guy doing this
training camp and we're having so much
fun during training camp in Atlanta he's
doing strain camp in Atlanta and then
his coach and just his whole experience
is just a good dude man yeah huge fan
was something had something to say that
versace cove but if you're him you can
wear a Versace coat wow that was a great
coat yeah that's a great coat you take
that hat off
okay how about Tom post hats and I wait
I text when he would get a lot of heat
about your hats huh
I had some picture my house I go I'm
gonna support you to watch this and I'd
post that online I mean I said I said
you and Kristen get that Lilly a little
bit get that off just then Chris threw
away a pair of sunglasses he had he we
were in his new Audi or whatever the
hell is doesn't some amazing car and I
and he was there with his long hair and
he had these gold Glatt they were gold
like they were like 1800 sunglasses and
I looked at him and I went I was like
man you're my friend but you have this
car and those sunglasses like he just
looked like such a dick and he started
laughing so hard him he said I never
wore the sunglasses again I go I I just
know what to say and he's like he was so
proud of his car and his son guys I go
man yeah you're in my book I wouldn't be
friends I'm usually like you're my
friend and you have this car and those
sunglasses all I need here you know
sometimes you need a friend to be like
alright we've really hit the low right
man because I can't actually abide by
all of this which is how I feel about
your [ __ ] hat alright the hell I
haven't talked my boy pin I'll write the
head all the time pin would have said it
he's got his hats and his then from that
dog and I may have to I may have to have
a conversation with him or you shall
accept put the dog down
your [ __ ] dog that off unless she's
just giving so many girls from that dog
that makes sense
hey right the dog put the dog down a lot
of pictures you done it's all right it's
just we all you know so you tell his
friends we all have to I don't know I I
tried I talked I tried to start wearing
a hat a long time ago I had Imperial
leather pants on but the thing is if you
can wear a hat you everything else has
to be in order
like you got a yellow half style to
start you just can't start with a hat
you love you know it's a question so I
get it yeah I love that you really do
yeah I love it you [ __ ] like it
really loves something yeah obsessed
those those as terrible as terrible as
those and offensive as those Gucci boots
are and we all know they are and there's
no one who likes them how big of a hit
are they on stage yeah here's the thing
you get him off no no no no no listen
get him off I mean today and I they went
to the meeting there's one request you
know they don't wear those [ __ ] weird
those boots Wow we gotta see him
personally I can't do it I can't wear
them on the show no it's a buckles it's
a and and they're good for a leprechaun
parade they're good for something like
that I don't know what they're good for
now listen you know I wish my friends
opinions especially my fit your friends
unfasten matters to me I can't I would
change but I have a point of view on
this good solid listen to you more I'm a
little right about this oh yeah no yeah
my yeah they make me mad I think you
matter then Chris is so it's gonna be
tough to hand those those are the Mo's
are really tough there's gonna be tough
Doug I need a leather jacket there I'm
gonna up my fashion game I'm wearing
these late look yeah I know you can't
project thing you get the business socks
on so can't wear those huh yeah that's
what you do man now I can't help it
not what I say in the mirror when I
looked in the mirror today I was not
good not good when you're 50 it doesn't
it's not like when I'm 51 things are
gonna be better now it's now it's just a
downhill slide but I'll fight like you
each year well till I go on TRT when do
you think you'll lose your hair well I'm
on probation
in fact I ran out gotta go get some
today so it's been three days so I'm not
gonna that's a game changer when you
lose you're here well I'm not gonna lose
my hair because I will get another hair
transplant and I'll go on propecia and
I'll be sure I don't know what I'll do
what about a wig
I always thought absolutely it's 215 so
they're getting way better I want to
wear cologne because it's too much
trouble
you guys no way cool that's true forget
it like some days you have it sometimes
you don't it's off to the side the trt
was gonna be I can't wait to get on
testosterone you'll lose your hair
faster not if I take my pretty propecia
I don't know if those two may well I'm
looking into it we'll see
but what's DRT gonna do for a 50 I guess
just more you don't have energy problems
you're just well that's right we're
about gravities don't want to [ __ ] with
my indifference system but I saw Tom
Cruise and the mummy I didn't watch it I
just put it on as I was and on the plane
to measure how long we were going he's
he is so muscular he had a shirt off
he's 50 something he looks fantastic
oh well but I mean he's definitely doing
something there well you know he's
definitely doing something you know Tom
Cruise and Bryan Callen that sound crews
that's tall and I'm sorry listen to me
right now bro hey rogue that doesn't
mean I can't I saw LeBron James's shirt
off with the same age that LeBron James
hey man athletic I can get muscular if I
start lifting weak at me and get on t
ARDS right now that's Tom Cruise the
biggest act of our jittery show so what
was he shredded for mummy yeah it's Tom
Cruise what about it Top Gun Tom Blues
you Bobby
mmm musk you if I put my mind to it
that's not good [ __ ] he looked good sure
yeah very power I remember I what I did
a reading with him we were walking to
the bathroom he was in front of me I was
looking at his body he is a thick dude
thick why sure short but thick soon
person I would call thick thick and
powerful powerfully-built sloped
shoulders just powerfully built small
face the actor he's four small for an
actor he's small dear for an actor he's
small dude for an actor he's also Tom
Cruise
though beasts Tom critters super beast
still doing it a high level yeah man he
I mean he's just making movie after
movie after movie my friend did a movie
he's freaking out a little bit well my
friend spent six months with him I won't
talk with her about it and he she had
nothing but good things say but she said
his life is only that he doesn't have
anything outside of yes so everybody
that he knows really and stuff are
people that he works with when he says
yes to a movie a whole machine moves
right and as you want people that work
yeah and so all those people that you
that that are kind of your assistants
your bodyguards he's got the same
bodyguard that he's had for twenty years
your chef your producers they're all
people that you you that rely on you and
you rely on them and that becomes your
family and and so everything that
happens happens on set everything and
and also that costs a lot of money the
funny thing about that is that when you
have the charge of a hundred people it
costs you a fortune so you gotta kind of
keep making movies in a way you have a
lot I've heard other things about what
he's doing I feel he suffered was
property of great things about him I
have to I've heard I've heard like when
he does a movie he's a piece like you
want tell about guy who won't delegate
any you know jobs didn't once we control
everything they say he actually does it
like in a super high level everybody I
know one of the biggest freaks in
Hollywood ever everybody's worked with
him do this this this thing gold this
here you're here monster and he's really
he's got he everybody I know who works
with him or has work with them and I
know people who spent a year with him
and more from Joe karna and the Todd
Phillips to Cobie Smulders I mean people
who you know they all say he's the
nicest guy in the world and he's he is
so you're right he's so detail-oriented
but he's also so passionate about acting
I did when I did this reading with him I
was like he and I and he was like acting
full-on like he was full-on acting like
where there was a scene incredible yeah
and the scene where we were coming back
were at the table reading and did you
get by well I probably would have
because Todd Phillips was directing it
it was called men and and I had a great
part I've had
my scenes were with him do you get the
part bro I didn't get the parts they
make the movie they day after a year he
decided no yeah and there was like
rewrites and everything else and it just
didn't that happens one of those close
calls which should be some current event
current events let's go to current
events you [ __ ] and we got a chinder
shirt happening in the works right now
I'll teach speaking of Chandler what's
up with that anything new I did some
research would go oh yeah so this
weekend there is more people more girls
what do you mean more girls that
actually like me oh but like 90 percent
of them there's three three girls black
girls really big black girls love it
which I have no problem with but I
wasn't attracted to it also yeah well
nobody do drop it no problem is you
don't like fat girls yeah it's just not
my type yeah so that's that and then
there's a really hot like white girl
that I thought was - is she was too hot
okay so she sent me like a little flower
message what do you say and then I
waited cuz you know I heard if it's a
bot they respond right away so I waited
nothing after that and that sent her a
pizza emoji because I thought it'd be
funny to go get pizza I don't know I
just thought I just try something and
then 40 but a few hours later nothing so
I'm like whoa yeah you [ __ ] possible
and then like later and I said if you
want to [ __ ] oh that's what Pizza worked
web camera all the pizza work correct
you want trying to [ __ ] yeah and then
there's one right now that I'm just not
attracted to but she can we see him him
yes what just a [ __ ] just a giant dick
huge you know we're making a tinder
shirt right now it's me hilarious but
she's you know Jay has some friends who
are of Asian descent and all of them
maybe all of his friends are but keep us
true Jalen hangs out the Asian tie and
it's very strange anyways
well family of seven here chin you're
not ready to be a dad I mean she's cool
though
well don't Photoshop yourself said it
she had a hot set of teeth on her
her eyes are cool she has 17 kids um how
are the peepers are a problem that's
gone well no sir eyes are gorgeous she
is f sharp set of teeth on her she's hot
although she check this out B so doing
some research darkness some Asian fellas
they love this segment cuz they said
they're going through the exact same
thing chin is it's not that you don't
have options they said Asian man in
America they just it's him on these
dating websites it's always been like
this they have the lowest success rate
for whatever reason as an Asian man in
America it's just tough to find
connection like this deep burn doesn't
joke about that because Asian women they
date white guys a day black guys they
date Mexican guys they just don't think
nice
yeah so like all of you know there's
like three of them they're like tell
Chan like we love this thing because we
get it man like we're on their all time
we're swiping non-stop we don't get a
lot of connections because as an Asian
man America it's a [ __ ] nightmare
that's weird
remember I forgot to talk about this but
we were in San Francisco I told you I
took an uber pool do you remember we met
in the green room after I met two girls
yes yes
one was a doctor and one was a lawyer
super pretty
so I'm actually messaging with them I
know type move yeah hey doctor doctor
they were pretty but an uber rule yeah
Wow so those shoe and then that girl
that that I do dig right now New York
they knew yeah she was Basinger with her
she's hot as [ __ ] see we got some fish
on the line I was 19 I dated a 35 year
old cardiologist and that was hot yeah
my dad took me about golf camp and I was
like God of grace is so much fun not my
hair but chin so it's true though like
Asian man in America it's a struggle
like on the day naps it apps maybe but
not in like a real life now in real life
did the lowest success rate well I don't
know well so you said my situation was
wait wait no like you're saying like we
can't find girls or my situation where
I'm like I'm not your situation we would
there's some matches but like like I
know if you were white we I'd feel like
we'd have yeah anymore match dude when
you go on the dating apps they're all
white yeah they're like a 90% white and
then once in a while you'll see an Asian
girl and then you do not attract it to
that asian girl yeah so I saw maybe two
Asian girls that were okay throughout
this entire thing yeah but I get DM they
get emails and then my brother's friends
who are of Asian descent we're saying
like tell Chan we get it man that sucks
like for us is Asian Americans like you
know if it's like black white Mexican
Asian we're the last you know if we're
playing dodgeball you Alaska babe it's
true that's why that's why my Asian
singing group
we just knew it's not gonna hit the
world's not ready for that
but maybe America's not what was it yeah
not America that's I mean what was the
name of your lousy America not the world
yes so the Americas there's a huge band
kpop band right now they're [ __ ] in
Asia slowly killing that's true they're
not big what's the name here what was
the name of your Asian verse first yeah
never heard of verse yeah yeah you're
doing better if some got sufficient
audience and everyone even at your shows
there's people like coming up to me
saying they want to introduce me to this
person well so I just said DM me and
then one dude he wanted me to go to
Magic Mountain with their friends and
they were gonna hook me up with the girl
that'd be fun that'sthat's a good first
date are you working on next Saturday
started Saturday you know the show is on
Friday all that phone yes you go ticket
I was too hungover
dude you [ __ ] came with 25 Koreans to
my show Vietnamese are them fitting me
are there everything actually Oh 25 X
saurians
the one who's bit of a heckler when she
she was I told you remember I told you I
had to talk to him beforehand sometimes
she like it came out she's like yeah
Brandon I'm like God doing the show off
Brandon that's how we're gonna start
tonight Handan like you don't know what
you're doing they have no way they were
yeah brando too crazy you have a lot of
forever e everywhere we go Chileans
people Amy I need his figures I need
this he's got he's got long arms long
arms
Asian tentacle that goes far and you
started working out I just started yes I
mean I judge the body would you do not
Beachbody yet I'm gonna do that soon but
uh the track the I have two trains a
bhakta more like telchines set up yeah
I'll give them private training perfect
because my legs hurt right now I can't
even do right so I gotta get in shape
just to be in gym shape you think
weights no you just need to my legs are
killing me yeah yeah we just got but if
you don't work out you get worse no I'm
saying I'm I'm starting it now word I'm
getting you don't need to you just don't
set it up I'll set it up if after this
show we'll talk about it I'll see those
guys out to this and then you just go in
perfect I still need you at Tony's
number it won't be through Tony I'll set
it up okay yeah all right I'll set that
sounds good
ginger ginger files chinder smiles we're
getting closer though I'm paying closer
getting closer making some connections
you can't eat after this huh I sure
can't currents and then yeah that MJ we
don't you have no issues think about the
MJ's first show MJ came to the Laugh
Factory sold way more shirts cuz she was
selling sure bad days I've never yes
I'll take guess we've had it was like
she's really hot
um I haven't noticed uh it's a funny man
I'm watchin the whole Trump thing on
people of taking knees well tell you
what I mean you can side with raíces you
can do you know [ __ ] up all this other
stuff Ian tweet out and be you go after
the NFL can be a fuck-boy you [ __ ] with
the NFL you're [ __ ] with the real [ __ ]
up America if I want America now you
[ __ ] uh-huh I think I think this will
lead to some even bigger change well I
think that Trump is been an incredible
unifier in a lot of ways like that when
he does stuff like that people get
together like good owners and everybody
kind of cried white black everybody kind
of locks arms and they're like Americans
have such a defiant streak in them
as soon as they're told what to do by
some of their leader they're like you
know what [ __ ] this guy he's not our
leader though right he's an idiot he's a
he's a that you can't just because now
this day and age just because you're the
president's age doesn't make you our
leader yeah like if anything you you're
the enemy he's the enemy he's not leader
people are opposed him just because he's
in a leadership position yeah they're
opposing what he stands for
yeah and also because you kneel doesn't
mean you don't like your country or the
flag that you're what you're doing is
try to bring attention to an injustice
in your community or whatever I mean
it's just that's all it is you know you
know I'm saying so they put many people
booth the players who kneel jesting not
really they use NFL ratings are down
everything's down just [ __ ] high
stats that I'm I I don't I don't get
very political I know no one's here for
me I don't I
I'm out I'm off I'm done he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] amount very gum out yeah when he
attacks people on Twitter I'm
embarrassed he's embarrassing guy man
I'm finally embarrassed he's not a I
just don't think he's that smart I just
definitely don't think he's competent I
just think he's he's emotional he's so
[ __ ] emotional you know I don't know
I've never liked the guy I never liked
him as a person I think he I've always
said it I think he's a trumpet she's
about himself that's why I don't like
him did that's the reason I don't like
him I think he's about him sorry
I don't he's just not qualified I'm just
embarrassed what else good Jim this is
pretty crazy a brother and sister
accidentally had an incestuous
relationship they were raised in
separate foster homes met up started
Game of Thrones [ __ ] this is Game of
Thrones [ __ ] they met up started dating
they actually broke up she found out she
was pregnant and this is in France so I
guess in France you can't be parents if
you have an incestuous child but in this
case in this rare case they allowed them
both to be parents it makes sense yeah
kind of a you know the outlier that is
so interesting now when when brothers
and sisters have sex and have kid does
the kid come back thank you Johnstone
clear done that's his aunt there is a
higher
well you might have to you might have to
edit that chin okay sorry
Game of Thrones I'm all caught up by the
way I'm all [ __ ] caught up
get ready for spoilers oh don't do it
get ready for sport and then dunk - but
he just boils the fights to me he
doesn't pull the [ __ ] will no there's no
spoiling live events but when I gotta
tell games and football record the fire
sizzling here I've been busy all week
now watch him last night you'll blow it
for fight you kid like now I can't hold
off I don't look at my phone but does
the kid come out normal so apparently
there's a higher risk of various
handicaps and retardation and stuff like
that
if it's this 40% really man yeah when
you have so the Hapsburgs they would
they would constantly the famous story
of the Hapsburgs they would they would
have interbreeding because you are
royalty so you only breed with royal
brook blood by the time the heir to the
Hapsburg throne he had to be helped on
to his saddle and he had a he had an
underbite that was so pronounced
couldn't she love [ __ ] food dad dad
like he had to eat out of a straw it was
such an he was what they the were so
there's issues with it yeah yeah it's
never very it's never good to I had no
idea that's this that's a sad most they
grew up in different foster that's so
strange so that makes it way less creepy
yeah this is just complete accident
people do that all the time you know
they were talking about like so you see
that with couples and and you're with
dogs they're kind of like you look like
your dog well you look like a court look
human being you look like a German
Shepherd like I know you have two dogs I
look like one the one I know why oh my
god I look like a nun look you you look
at me if your dog would just all
somewhere round a human right yeah
German Shepherd you look at the working
class you look like a goddamn Corgi
fewer dogs that's your core igniter it's
your core you have the face of a core
you know nope either that or you look
like a bloodhound German Shepherd you
look like blood those that matter you
boys
they starting to fall off my face yeah
cuz my face drags on the ground so I
pick up scent Oh [ __ ] sniff do you
know why they have long hair its
sniffing you know what their ears are
why their ears drag on the ground
because they give zip pick up the scent
so I said so my job
pretty soon my job is gonna be hanging
on the ground hey but for reals you look
like your accord you do I was I was
doing a you ever like it when you're
older like me and you look down on a
mirror just just get in position
position and look down at your face man
veins everything your whole face is
hanging off you're looking down the poor
women in my life your face hangs off
like your face if you're down there yeah
if I'm look where's the mirror yeah but
I have you down at my wife as I'm but
ever it's our power [ __ ] yeah but
when would you see that vision I've
looked in the mirror so the times like
I've looked how so today that happened
what was I do maybe maybe your phone yes
my phone that's exactly what it was
my phone is on the ground you saw those
near me I looked down on my face and I
was like that's exactly what I was like
my face is simply falling off my skull
and that's not expressed get like
brisket and I can see a giant fan in my
forehead and I was like who the [ __ ]
would ever be able to have sex with that
guy well she signed a contract so it's
good like now on it's going to be from
behind though now here's the thing
they're talking about though it's you
know in Nietzsche always said that you
friendship a lot of friendship is
[ __ ] because a lot of friendship is
people make friends based on sort of
like how they compliment them like so
you'll have a friend and you only have
friend that usually people make friends
because they're like you they you look
they look like doing the saying the same
like this look this well that's the show
there's that kind of friendship or or
that or the friends compliment you so a
hot chick a lot of times we'll have
nothing but hot friends or she's got the
opposite all grin AIDS or grenades so
they look better
exactly and those aren't necessarily
real friends well friends sure but then
there are the friends that you just
truly enjoy hanging out with people that
just make you laugh and you hang and you
love well he's not writing anything
ground now and then there's friends in
there the friends that inspire you well
like you know you just went over the the
button but there are a lot of friends
there
a lot of friendships where people are
[ __ ] they just like you see them and
they're just they're only friends people
that that are just like them and you're
like look like relationship with you
liked it look like this like you got to
kind of speak the way you know
everything about the person what friend
sweet this similar language no you and I
are a flit no cliques we have so we have
similar lingo for sure we have Super
Friends of similar lingo yeah we have
similar lingo but yeah you want to be
friends with people I got a deeper swarm
friendship as people that kind of pushed
you and inspire you and a lot of people
don't necessarily have those bonds
now what did this have to do would you
look like your [ __ ] dog say thank God
deers or people get dogs a lot of times
people get dogs they say that identify
with how so they're like I identify with
that kind of look that kind of dog so
that's why I have a working line German
Shepherd see I'm uh I you can send me
into a [ __ ] where I hate that record
you just the biggest [ __ ] in the world
I got a working like Shepherd so if
there's a situation you send me in I
take that perp down I take the perp down
because I identify with a [ __ ] wolf
cuz you know I'm like wolf like where
you pointed now I'm wolf like man don't
say that I hate and you lots of the
nicest German shipper in the world how
do you talk I change the subject
next current event with OSI connected
all right this is a bad one all right
Hernandez after they tested his brain he
had severe CTE I think level three three
out of four and then his family suing
the NFL because of it now but senior bad
for the Nobel yeah he's through chronic
traumatic encephalopathy shame all the
way around well it was the most advanced
case they have seen at this stage what
they said his brain was of a mid
six-year-old
really yeah Wow hold on is that true
that's [ __ ] up man
Stage three she found in her name it
involves cognitive impairment trouble
with executive functions like playing
and organized I'd say so just so they
found early brain trophy and large
perforations and septum oh hey you sit
him well Sapolsky who's that behavioral
psychologist or whatever
like you know as we find out more about
the brain like that you can explain a
lot of human behavior and see but I
don't think in chalk it all up to the
NFL and all that stuff because it's
childhood [ __ ] you I fought a lot right
so he grew up in his mom was a drug
addict you didn't have a father he was
in gang activity so those were his
conditions then if you mix in the brain
trauma you know it's gonna be bad but
you can't chalk it all up to brains so
so apparently so apparently according to
Sapolsky in that book behave as you
people who grow up in circumstances of
poverty and stress and and things like
that and including when your mother did
drugs your prefrontal cortex will not
develop at the same rate so you actually
are mentally impaired it can have a
great deal to do with mental impairment
and that those parts of the brains
actually don't develop I would assume
that's what the NFL defense is gonna be
they're like wait what look at this
[ __ ] childhood yeah football didn't
help we should be part of their defense
hell yeah I think they're suing more not
for what happened over it did that
caused him to commit suicide so that's
what they're going for
you don't think the circumstance of him
going of course in her life because he
murdered three people is what he commits
suicide for an tip so the family of the
slain victims couldn't steal all of his
money goes to his kids
you don't think Stevie Stevie blue eyes
was talking about this he said that it
was not surprising at all that Aaron
Hernandez did that because they used to
always say in jail when you are in jail
and you know you're just around things
you can deal you can get
institutionalized and you're fine the
biggest danger is when you go out for a
month in a van and you're out in the
world for your trials so for a retrial
or you see your family and you spend a
great time that into the wall oh yeah
and then when you come back to yourself
that's when suicides happen he said a
lot of times when you just realize I
can't do this anymore because you're
reminded of what you're missing and so
for her to Aaron he was saying it away
before he goes and he was talking to his
buddies who are in jail he goes when
you're in a van and you're and you're
seeing people living their life and
you're going to
Boston and then you're in a courtroom
and you smell perfume and you see what
the world is like you see your family
now you got to come back to your cell
and you might be there forever
well his thing his biggest thing too is
his kids would his kid would have been
screwed over cuz they would took all his
money
so he's yeah he's worth more to them
dead than his life and there's that just
like Dalton it's sacrifice I don't know
man it's a shame but you know as much as
brain trauma CT we we see you've only
seen the worst-case scenarios like we
know it's bad for you you know me guys
out there that don't have issues correct
a lot a lot or maybe they do they don't
know because they can't tell the numbers
on the phone well whose beau caman beau
camp played ten years in the NFL 65 now
owns a bunch of restaurants I talked to
him about it and he said I have he goes
all my friends who are my age now
because I I mean I know it's a real
thing but he said most of my friends
we're all fine at 65
I mean he's fine so it depends on your
it depends on your health of course it's
an issue of it so oh so there's this guy
I met at in Madison he's a he works in
Cleveland as an engineer in the [ __ ]
what is it called but it's a medical
place and they're coming up with a and
he actually had it with him a mouthpiece
with a computer chip in it and that will
read the kind of trauma you take to your
head so so based on how you bite down
and all this stuff I guess and vibration
through the mouthpiece and it's it's
going to have and it'll have an app on
your phone so there'll be a guy
eventually you'll have your mouthpiece
we'll take readings of the kind of head
trauma you take and say well he can't
play anymore right because it hits a
certain marker and they go that's a
concussion still in I mean little
tougher helps but yeah you're concussed
thank you
yeah well you'll have to sit out based
on a certain number that the phone gives
you so that's all coming that's good
yeah good okay a dude robbed a Starbucks
right with a mask and a knife and it's a
and a fake gun and the guy that was near
him took him down someone that wanted to
disarm him took him down and beat him up
so badly that he's now suing the guy
that disarmed him but the guy that
disarmed him I read later on he stabbed
him with like 13 times survivor times or
70 times they were severed 17 stab
wounds rightfully so man I mean that's
what that does give me some
repercussions you rob a store and
homeboys there and my 15 times though
but hey man maybe so if you want to get
a guy who is holding on the guy who had
the knife no the guy's armed him the guy
who disarmed took the knife right it's a
little tricky I don't know Jerry was
stabbed once in the neck oh that's a big
deal
maybe so he was fighting for his life so
he got stabbed in the neck he took the
knife out and stab all challenges oh I'm
sorry Jerry the [ __ ] we should be
honoring as a hero in San Francisco
Starbucks got stabbed in the neck
apprehended this [ __ ] [ __ ] took the
knife and just he's not equipped to
handle these high-pressure situation so
he stabs guys 17 times yeah I mean I
don't have a problem with it yeah I got
stabbed in the neck that's different
stepped in that sucks that's super
dangerous Oh how'd it go down I mean
dude I got I got a [ __ ] needle I got
two needles in my neck I did that
Prolotherapy where they shoot saline
solution into your muscles lie neck was
so bad back in the day my neck was so
back so I go to this doctor and it's
called Prolotherapy so they'll shoot the
saline solution in your in your muscles
and apparently had rushes blood cells to
it or some [ __ ] he stuck that [ __ ]
needle in my neck and I went ahh it was
so painful I was like what the you know
that guy won't do no man no actually we
operate in the Starbucks here oh yeah
he's 21 months transferring obscene
material to a minor you said in dick
pics and stuff right yeah how old was
the minor
we coulda got 10 years that could have
been the max yeah so he's almost getting
two years in prison
god dammit Wiener Wiener wiener also
though you would like come on dude oh
also the kid there was a picture where
his little 15 year old girl angered play
had duel up wiener pled guilty and made
a sex in with a 15 year old in North
Carolina did he know she was 15 though
you have to register the sex offense a
sound if I see a girl
I'm gonna know if she looks remotely if
she looks 19 I ain't doing my god you
know you never know 15 you should be
very paranoid of that stuff
[ __ ] wiener come on man it's Weiner
what else you got chin all right
so I got this cutie pie dog after the
Mexico wakes this dog actually helps
save 50-plus lives and 12 them were like
critical critical condition that she
actually helps say those goggles this
awesome dude I was talking about how in
Mexico like that the construction is not
good and this [ __ ] guy shows hey yeah
and the DM goes Brian you [ __ ] racist
Mexico is a first world country we have
amazing construction the earthquake was
just [ __ ] super-strong you [ __ ]
and that's why some buildings collapsed
that was like oh sorry I'm really sorry
you guys it's okay I'm a longtime
listener I was like all right sorry all
due respect what a badass hell yeah I'm
super cute awesome they can smell they
can smell some crazy [ __ ] dogs have good
life here but Captain Obvious dogs
connect so now we're gonna shorten you
know dogs have good sense I don't smell
really well bomb dog let's see they use
them in avalanches to somebody's flow
yeah they use his their dead friend's
ashes as bait nikhat the biggest carp in
the world type mu win it carps eat ash
well they combine baby worms in them
no they combine into this little thing
called boilies it's a little bait that
they they mound up in their hands and
their body used to go fishing with them
ended up getting cancer and this is
their tribute to them that's cool there
guy the far right looks like he's
struggling
guys that might be in like water looks
dirty god damn that thing is huge
[ __ ] huge carp
that's an arapaima but that's the carp
right there that's the carp yeah what
are the [ __ ] attrition at Amazon Oh
Thailand yeah our set of titties dude
those are some tits and aren't there
crocodiles in in Thai waters in Thailand
aren't there big crocodiles in that
water
get the [ __ ] out there hunting with
their hands don't you hunt catfish with
your hands right yeah but not when you
answer those muddy what holes are small
to medium-sized freshwater crocodile
I'd say small kill my [ __ ] for fresh
water salt use that salt one Salty's you
got to worry about what else all these
have so much acid in their stomach they
can dissolve nails God dog teacher
literally slept with 14 students to in
the same night you hot I find this so
she's not bad well not always
they're always hot you know why we put
him in jail that [ __ ] she's 25 yeah
fantastic
hey this hilarious fan a New Jersey
woman admits forcing 16 year old into
hellish life of sexual slavery really
what happened click on that for more
than that she's hot she [ __ ] two dudes
the same night whatever go to New Jersey
woman admits a 16 year old into hellish
life
what murder yes you wait was she the one
forcing the helis she's a force she's
poor her name is China white she's
pretty hot hold up what's going on here
Jed
a New Jersey woman went by the name
China white great pleaded guilty
forcing 16 year-old girl from New York
to go into prostitution so that's sex
slaves
yeah human half cool it was guys who
were you know yeah it's working for
dudes oh so she was like the pimp yeah
I'm like the middleman yeah
[ __ ] that's horrible yep because they
would put an ad in and a cop answered it
you know it was a sting operation and it
was the girl she was 16 faces seven
years in prison and a woman told him
that he could have full sex with her six
dollars cash in the moat it was a
husband white look at that
[Music]
she except 106 dollars in cash yeah Wow
poor girl man yeah all the time it
physical violence should not fall
through the rules and perform to the
expectations
Jesus Christ man what a piece of [ __ ]
that couple is yeah very bad people
remember we're talking about the IKEA
thing ah there's some strange guys
around you two strange guys around that
yeah remember I was like how could that
be possible that I got messages like
crazy going like no that's where that's
where things like that happen I kill you
yeah when it's packed
they just snag the kids Christ it's
[ __ ] horrifying oh very scary that's
good I think that's it man all right
good [ __ ] I'm gonna go pee again
so my dropping knowledge is again about
confirmation bias which is something we
all suffer from right so when you have a
feeling or a belief you will do whatever
you can to look for it and this Islamic
scholar went and kind of like
interviewed a lot of jihadists and
extremists and found that there are some
most of them don't know a whole lot
about the Quran they just don't know a
lot they have a very rudimentary idea
but what happens is there are some
obscure texts like tiny texts that start
making the rounds on all the forums in
the ISIS forums and all these long forms
basically predicting that you know the
end of times is near it's very very
prevalent among like most Giada's but
also the idea that you know everything
that's happening now has been predicted
in the Quran and he found them and I
just want to give you an example of how
P and we all do this we all do this we
all will try to find like some obscure
thing as it says it in the Bible or it
says it right here or if you watch this
YouTube thing you can see was it this
CIA guy said it way back then and it's
like you hear this all the time and it's
very easy to confirm your bias with
evidence if you know where to look
you're cherry-picking but this is a very
real issue among and it's really what
gives fuel to a lot of young people
they're not even histor than what in the
arguments because they don't even know
the Quran they're just like it's said in
the Quran here it is so here's an
example of
of essentially I guess we're talking
about where where they basically said
that Quran predicted HIV and climate
change and here is the passage and think
about how obscure this is corruption has
appeared and it's an obscure hadith it's
it's what like it's what Muhammad said
is the hadith an item Quran he said
corruption has appeared throughout the
land and sea by reason why what the
hands of people have earned so he may so
corruption up has appeared throughout
the land and say climate by reason of
what the hands of people have earned so
he may let them taste part of the
consequence of what they have done that
perhaps they will return to
righteousness that's the that's pretty
obscure okay but that's thrown around
that line predicted HIV it's not even in
the Quran but it's an obscure
translation of a hadith again the things
that Muhammad said that is considered
untrustworthy by mainstream Islamic
scholars then it says it never happens
at permissiveness overwhelms of people
to the extent that they display their
acts of sex shamelessly and they are not
uniquely that they are not uniquely
punished by God among them invariably
pestilence which is disease is made to
spread and such other diseases the like
of which have never been witnessed by
their forefathers that's those are two
examples of what are thrown around as
proof that the Quran predicted climate
change and HIV and there are so many
different examples of this and I read
through all of them I don't have time to
but the bottom line is remember that or
for example here's one that predicted
the Iraq war the last hour would not
come before the Euphrates uncovers a
mountain of gold Euphrates is the river
that goes through Iraq uncovers a
mountain of gold for which people would
fight that's passed round as proof that
the Quran predicted the era and this is
this is mainstream among extremists and
jihadists and it just goes to show you
how propaganda can be twisted to
basically show you and prove to you that
you're feeling because you're
marginalized or whatever that that this
that I'm on the right side of right and
this book has the truth even though
mainstream islamic scholars would be
like dude you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about here
thousand examples of why you're wrong no
no no no no but it's but the most
important thing to realize is that yes
that is part of what fuels young men to
join Isis and things like that however
we all have a little Isis in us we all
CrossFitters tend to look at the whole
world as a gym
vegans tend to think that everything can
be cured with green vegetables the
obviously Isis takes a little too far
they'll chop you're fucking-a devices
yeah bro yeah you got a little Isis in
you bro you actually you actually are
not that way you're actually pretty good
at a lot of people you're pretty [ __ ]
moderate but you know just just just get
that old one was tricky though what's
that that gold it's all tricky it's all
tricky but it'sit's how you motivate
large groups of young mana you you find
obscure passages it's like numerology
you know what that is in the in the in
the Bible like in my Kabbalah and stuff
where you can do it you know connect
numbers and you can connect verse and
stuff like that you can do that with
anything that with with the Constitution
so be careful oh we're all nicest oh we
all have a little separation that's
right
it's important to know we're gonna be
Abie for comedy like that glad you asked
buddy well my friend I will be doing
that and I'll be talking about nothing
but Isis and reading from the quran long
passages from the Koran I hope you guys
don't mind just [ __ ] cricket and I
just keep reading uh I will be it in
[ __ ] Philadelphia Philly they love
Billy's gonna put up with a lot and I
said and the Hadees and Mohammed I'll be
in yah be in Philadelphia the City of
Brotherly Love where something called
the Constitution was right that's right
man you should go over that topic was
founded and seal will you take it still
that's right do you know what
what wrong do you know what Ben Franklin
liked what he had to do with electricity
which I kind of didn't know it either
looks right well no like you know how
they say invented electricity of course
he didn't right but what did he do did
wasn't he the one who found it like
basically
sort of he tamed it in a way right yeah
he's the one basically bottle it right
well he created the lightning rod I
guess it was like sort of like he he
flew a kite and was figured out that you
could harness lightly like the gods you
weren't at the mercy of it you could
actually you could actually put a
lightning rod up and you could actually
attract lightning you could actually get
God to shoot it at a certain place he
figured out that there were there were
conductive materials like metal that
would cause lightning actually hit it
it's kind of interesting so you know
kind of like the first gotta tame the
gods so he invented the quote-unquote
lightning rod there are lightning rods
which you never think about but I guess
there are we put you don't want to like
if you're if they're if you're hair
standing on end and you're on a golf
course
yeah you might want to run don't lift
your golf club how about the fact that
[ __ ] now if the lightning will hit the
ground and in where was it in like
Norway it hit the ground and 300
reindeer just [ __ ] die they just died
well describe water on the ground I
guess so right so it was a good
what just happened to people oh yeah
[ __ ] I didn't realise water electricity
man wear rubber shoes that's why always
we should put rubber hooks on all so
you're safe in a car yeah that's where
you're safe in a car buddy Hetal within
the ground
can you yeah I don't know either i
guilty Brian Philly we're both the
Comedy Store tomorrow night we sure are
at the Comedy Store tomorrow nice Joe
Rogan Sam Tripoli excited about that
Russell Peters yeah fun one my next
shows not till November Colusa casino
there you go they see north towel NorCal
about an hour from Sacramento I'll be
fine but those tickets are on sale
yeah be great you know the back gate I
got for Brian listen you shouldn't I'll
tell you that day you're gonna be there
and the other thing but you guys should
know well there's breaking news I want
to do there's breaking news depends
depends if your cannibal are you well
right a Russian couple is suspected of
killing and eating up to 30 victims what
yeah it's a russian couple 13 oh man
could you not find I gotta find a xxx
mural 35 year old man four
woman and his wife boat well actually 35
year-old man they didn't tell the wife
was let you have murdered as many as 30
people since 1999 consumed parts of the
bodies they found a canned ham hand
somebody they can't a hand that's
attractive and they found I guess the
pictures of the guy on a on his phone
oh there's a picture yeah Hannibal
family crest kill an email so DPM
Russell they kept human remains in the
cellar of the house of horror and poster
selfies with the body parts scroll down
for the selfies please a former
policeman
he's charged with 60 additional murders
in addition to 22 that if the pair was
detained Oh what well I do picture a man
with what appears to be a hand in his
mouth oh my god the man had been killing
eight people since 1999 according his
confession oh that's the cannibal girl
eat this dick oh she was a recent victim
this is not good oh my god no it's not
we get the guy keeps going down chin
yeah there he is
he uh he looks pretty horrific what a
terrible thing what a terrible thing
they've done to be holy
no that is darkness at its finest its
darkness at his finance worked in
military again ever got me yeah what the
another prison was red showing human
head on a plate surrounded by oranges
look at that look at that
yeah only a god it keeps going down dark
not a jar but legend human reigns pick
hold ups up here used to keep either a
Russian drug core evolved to make the
victim sleep pickled in a jar I mean
it's just hold up they lived in a hostel
of a military aviation accountable on to
Russian Defense Ministry the work said
each time we tried to enter the room
they started wild shouting crying they
are so deeply depraved
I don't know what to say oh my god
that's nice so horrible some darkness in
this world but I mean man oh man and
they were just married they found each
other how the [ __ ] how do you breach
that subject with your wife like hey let
me ask you a question you like eating
people
I'll buy you buy me I bet you want to
eat me I do do you want to me yeah do
you want to eat somebody so you know
what I mean how do you how do you get
into that level of perversion some dark
[ __ ] it's some dark [ __ ] but I guess
they found each other they probably saw
each other and they're like I'd like to
eat that person what if let's say you
would eat me let's just say you had to
what part would you eat first on you
yeah and then I'll say well you got some
good meat on you where but you got a pic
probably back of your arm
you'd eat my tricep let me tough me it'd
be some tough meat right by your cheek
ease your little chica pues let's see
you got some cute cheeky pues sure got
all softy cheek buddy yes what what
gross
no no I didn't you know dude yeah I saw
you there yeah on the show you said I'd
eat your ass and you're like and you
were looking me in the eye no your Qi
you're attracted to me
no like I would bet the day I would
barbecue your ass cheese oh you guys you
said I want to eat your ass I'd eat your
ass it's so gross dude what would you do
peel my peach go to hell no Santa no I
would skin it off like you want to go
after my flat at all bro prashant
prosciutto shoot though bro no you said
you'd eat my cheeks or my triceps how's
that any different I'm training your
glutes no because you went I eat your
ass and you said it without like you
said it all loose your mouth stayed all
open yeah okay you're high no yeah it
came out wrong you worry me cuz you're
strong maybe I eat your hamstring you
told me down a get off I'd pickle your
ankles you would not pick your ankles
your old ass ankles feel like you'd be
like brisket
what they did they went to these
African GL and there was a guy who would
like when you were an inmate he would
bang you face to face so whenever you
think about it like these like raped in
jail you thinking you're on a cell wall
yeah yeah not so not so and he's like
face to face I'm looking you all right
when I do it yeah that's a rough way to
say habit to move that's a savage move
that's what you want made he is really
good
Oh clearly gay Kyrgyz are you gay no I'm
not gay
definitely doesn't that make you gay
nope it's just his way of like marking
your card mark your car no he's a
hundred percent gay but let's have to do
with young people well you said you want
to eat my ass yeah I guess 13s well you
know run an eating ass and breaking into
it with your dog are pretty much no bug
me I didn't say I wanna bring shame I do
not say I'm gonna break it you're just
short bit such a short little step no no
like it's a prime rib you're working my
buddy I'm talking about breaking when
you're at work at my bunny hole with
your Aurora tongue that's it's said well
that's what you want it's so sort sort
move to just kinda I was gonna barbecue
your ass get up there you want to be my
cheeky
well yeah cuz I was like eating you for
I'm not eating you to know you were
talking about you were talking about
enjoying me no yep in your area you're
stranded
no mm-hmm no I never cells gonna break
in you're talking about well that's what
you basically imply nilly and I'm
appalled if an offense if someone ever
says hey man I'm trying to break into
that ass yeah they're trying to [ __ ] so
says yo bro
you're some glute Sonia I'd love to
tenderize those things insane that grill
say they want to eat your who look at me
there was a Bosley you're smiled you
smiled
and you went out of your ass and then
your mouth hung who's not like that came
out wrong you know that you weren't
working out right came out of the truth
you know you guys they came out wrong
yeah I was getting your glutes genies
out of the bottle and your hands
everybody should see your hands are so
pressed to your thighs right now like a
bad boy like you've been a bad boy his
hand is City love Noah is that so it's
bad but I said I'll eat your ass his
hands are all I'm saying there's a lot
of meat in your glutes your hands are
right your hands are touching besides
your thighs like a good boy you're like
you're like you've been disciplined you
got caught with your cookies with your
fingers in the cookie jar with your
fingers in the button you're trying to
break in the mouth you got your fingers
you break into my ass but I never said
that yeah you trying to break don't try
to turn around I got this whole car
you're talking about cookies in the food
jar cookies in my but jar yeah all right
moving on me breaking that ass well
Brian let me get me a watch you do that
buddy I'm gonna give me a bunch of
watches have fun chatting with this -
chatting with chat with you this Monday
morning buddy we're friends
we don't eat cheese enjoy each other I
don't eat cheese anymore stop date and
I'll tell you what yeah I looked a
little I don't know I'm I guess I'm more
bothered that you're you have some Isis
in you that's why I take away from this
pocket yeah you should you have Isis any
look likee I just think if you don't
really if you don't agree with me chop
yeah all right that makes sense
my back is all bunched up though gotta
go take some in anti-inflammatory you
have fun flying to Philly on when things
get back bunched up whoa t factor.com
for tickets Brian myself this is the
farm kid route